... and now I can't go
to the Disney Store.
Is she close by?
Okay, if any of my 213 followers
is in the Midtown Mall,
we just found a dope little girl
and her parents aren't here,
but she's fine.
She's with us, but-
What's your name?
Gadanna.
Gadanna. That is gorgeous.
Madonna, Rihanna,
Alana, Gadanna.
Whoa. Dude, that's good.
... in the corner.
Mommy, can I go
explore over there?
Hold on one sec, all right?
So, we're going to security,
but we're riding the escalator
which is more fun
and it gives us
more time with Gadanna.
Totally, dude.
No. I mean, it's insane.
Like, what? She's two. I'm 30.
I mean, I could
literally be her mom.
I mean, if I was just walking
around this, you know,
the mall by myself and people
saw me just shopping with her,
they'd be like,
"That's a mom and her kid."
You're crazy.
Me? I'm crazy? No.
No.
She not.
Mommy, mommy, mommy.
Oh, Gadanna. You have
taught us so much.
Yeah, we're really
gonna miss you.
Okay, maybe we can just do
like a double cheek kiss?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Double cheek ...
Really just ...
Double cheek kiss, ready?
Excuse me? What the ...
are you doing with my child?
Mommy?
Abbi? College Abbi?
Did you take Bella?
No, we didn't take her.
She was clearly stranded.
You should keep better
track of your kids.
Oh, grow up, Abbi. We're 30.
Why the ... are you filming her?
Why the ...
are you stealing her?
... bitch. Fucking bitch.
Go. Open the door.
[inaudible 00:02:22]
Go. You out. Yes.
You're such a perv.
Oh, you can't leave.
You perv.
So, we just downloaded
that story for evidence,
but now the rest
of Manhattan ...
No, I mean, what a ... bitch?
Like, what a mess?
Like, we are so not
pedophiles, dude.
No.
I mean, her name is Cheese.
It's not really Cheese.
No, whatever her name is.
Listen, all this girl
wanted to do in college
was like ecstasy
and take group showers.
Ones that I never even wanted
to be a part of by the way.
Even if she would've asked me,
I would've never done it.
Yeah.
And now she has a bunch of ...
kids and she thinks she's ...
better than me?
No.
She thinks she's better than me?
Bullshit.
We're coming to you men.
Bumming.
Hey.
Thank you so much.
Happy birthday.
Thank you.
Hey, happy birthday.
Thanks.
Alana, what happened?
Oh, God. Okay, so ...
(singing)
What is this?
Hey.
Hey. Hey, Abbi.
[Spanish 00:03:48]
Yo, yo, yo, yo.
Okay. Let's do this quick
before she gets back.
Happy Birthday, Abbi.
I hope you have
the most amazing one.
I love you so much.
I hope the 30s are everything
you expect them to be
and I'm really happy
it's happening to you before me.
You are older than me.
That's why I say this.
God, dude. I remember my 30s.
All I had was a beeper.
A freaking beeper.
Nobody had freaking cellphones.
Every two minutes,
checking your phone.
I'm so happy
I didn't grow ...
Cheers, Abbi. Happy birthday.
I'm so excited to celebrate this
momentous occasion with you.
I feel like this is your year.
So, you need to do
something with it.
If I know my baby's
poop schedule,
she is just about finished.
Look at this. How cute is this?
Okay, here we go.
Thank you guys so much
for all the sweet messages.
Yay, Abbi.
I also saw the new butt video.
Okay, the lady doth not
protest though, so.
They're good pants for butt.
Really good.